i was struck by um i heard that there
wasn't that they had never had
an officer motion that was ruled um
not or inappropriate or wrong and i said
how can i be that there's no way that
100 percent know that was during the
days of the coroner's inquest
viewed by many as one-sided hearings
about use of force
incidents at the hands of officers
critics said it led officers off the
hook
and the clark county commission heard
from community members like rhonda
gibson
in 2011 her husband stanley an unarmed
war veteran
was shot and killed by metro police i
don't want my husband's debt to be in
vain
in 2013 six members of the use of force
board
resigned the board which was created in
the 90s reviews use of force incidents
at the hands of police
then sheriff doug gillespie went against
board recommendations
and refused to fire an officer who shot
an
unarmed man he survived the board found
the officer had mistaken the sight of a
shiny sticker on a hat
for the medal of a gun as sheriff i have
the last say in these matters
internally motion passes that same year
the commission ruled to
end the inquest now in addition to a
public fact-finding review where
information is publicly released the use
of force board holds more weight to
decide whether an incident is justified
one recent example after the in-custody
death of an
unarmed black man byron williams in
2019.
the use of forceport identified problems
with how officers handled williams
and what followed at the scene the metro
police department
then made policy changes the board
includes three commissioned officers and
four
citizens from a pool of 20 which donovan
britt david skelton and richard metzler
are part of
i would say the majority of our cases
that i've served on this year haven't
even
haven't involved the use of a gun it's
been other issues where the person died
going hands on what's important to
myself and probably every member of the
board is transparency
it's what we look for there has to be
someone on that bridge that people can
trust and say look
i was in that room this is what i saw i
was on the scene
i spoke to the chief we spoke as a group
together and i'm telling you this is how
this case
went now at the same time there also has
to be that that notion that we can be
critical
and supportive at the same time
you